[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down episode 6 of gen
B the latest entry might make you wonder
what's going on but in this video we're
going to explain everything to take you
out of those shades of Jean Gray there's
lots of Easter eggs comic book callbacks
and things you missed in it plus a cameo
that was like ruined 4 weeks ago on
social media but we're here now to talk
about it all Heavy spoilers ahead so if
you haven't had a chance to check it out
then I highly recommend that you check
out now if you enjoy the video please
hit the thumbs up button and don't
forget to subscribe for breakdowns like
this every day by the way huge thank you
for clicking this now let's get into gen
V now we begin with Kate making Emma
remember everything we can catch her
bloodshot eyes which may be a nut to
what happens to the psychic when their
poers overload in fire starter this is
also a subtle way to show when Kate's
Powers have been used and if we go
through the season there's several
moments where she she'd clearly been
overdoing it now when we cut to the
wider shot we can catch Marie standing
in front of a girls get it done poster
this still contains storm for on it but
she was eventually recast with Charlie
thone once the truth about her got out
up next to Jordan we can also see the no
ly lose sign that popped up at the start
of episode 2 around the room there's
several dawn of the seven posters
including character ones from Starlight
and black noir we also get a shot of
Emma standing by an American flag though
this may also be homelander Cape now
Kate starts to collapsed due to her
powers overloading and it even seems
like she reads Mar and Jordan's mind why
did she do this to us I'll never foret
for this as we see throughout the
episode she's way more powerful than we
ever suspected with her very much being
a reality warper just like how wonder is
Gan gray also feels like she's a basis
for the character too with us getting
several nods to the X-Men throughout
upstairs we then see Andre in a room
with a neon Phoenix sign on the wall
which could be a no to Jean Gray's
Persona this is actually where we saw
the fire breather last week and just
below the coffee table we can catch a
kind of Turbo rush I'm guessing that's
getting mixed with vodka at the party um
I'm a bit hung over myself today so see
seeing everyone here I I could relate to
it a bit now he believes that K
convinced Luke to kill Brink and thinks
she had a similar plan for him Marie's
also starting to regret what she wished
for as she thought joining godu was the
best day of her life however it's not
all it's cracked up to be and it's using
the students to further its own ends
after catching Kake going into his
seizure we see as the world transformed
around them with her sucking them into
her subconscious also love how just
before it kicks off Marie asks Jordan if
they know CPR you learn CPR where at
superhero School Jesus obviously you'd
expect them to be learning how to save
lives at superhero school but this place
is more about branding and appearing
like a hero rather than actually being
one this is something Andre deals with
with his dad because he realizes that
he's not really a hero now we could
across to the woods where we see a
prisoner called Betsy that has
electrical powers these manifests
similar to electros with them being go
like his more comic accurate depictions
Betsy also has a name that you only ever
really hear Comic characters have with
Betsy brck being the first one that
Springs to mind sorry if you called
Betsy and you're watching this but you
know what I mean it's not I'm not saying
this oldfashioned don't hit the thumbs
down mate come on there are Comic
characters where Betty's name either
either way we find out the virus is
attached to V and that it's attacking
the Sals and making her sick kadosa has
it ready to sign off but shedy would
rather concentr the dose and make her
feel sicker now I feel like with it
being related to blood that the plans to
use Maria as someone that can spread it
this would mean that they have a way to
wipe out every soup on the planet and
take characters like homelander down if
he goes Rogue it's something that V
would be interested in as they're pretty
much at the whims of them being well
behaved I feel like making soup sick
isn't something Marie would sign up for
though and that's the part where Kake
comes in she's already under shed's
control and Shetty could tell Kate to
tell Marie what to do now back with Kate
we see Dusty come in and shout out to
this guy is's wearing a berserk shirt
now she ends up seemingly teleporting
out of there but instead it's clear that
this is actually her mind making the
Wall fall apart they all step outside
and see that they're all trapped in an
illusion this takes them out into into
the woods which is metaphorically
building off the back of the experiment
however it's also because this is a
defining moment for Kate as it was when
her family fell apart in the comics Kate
would be class as an Omega Level threat
which is someone that would be an
extreme danger to humanity maybe the
virus is even to control her but she has
the potential to do a lot of damage in
case you haven't read House of M that's
probably the quintessential W maximoff
story though she doesn't feature in it
too much it does showcase what happens
when her full powers are Unleashed now
in the aftermath of Avengers
disassembled The Avengers decided that
it was just safer to kill her traveling
out to janosa she reacts badly to it and
transforms the entire world into war
where mutants are the dominant species
this is got Humanity on the back for and
they could even do something like that
with the soups in the comics they wanted
to take over the world and reversing
things like that would of course cause
it to happen so it's reasons like that
that she has to stay on top and we see
the firstand damage that her powers have
caused out in the woods we see Kate's
mother looking for her brother Caleb and
we learn in episode three what happened
with him Kate told him to walk into the
woods and unfortunately he never came
back Kate's mother's blamed her for this
ever since and we have this idea of bad
parents La throughout the show as we
know they were the ones who gave their
kids V and this was so they could become
soups the kids themselves though they
never got a choice and they've been
forced into this life of trying to be a
superhero the only choice they have is
to go and work for vort or get shipped
off to somewhere like Elmyra or Sage
Grove though they're powerful they're
completely powerless and it's purely
down to their parents' choices now this
scene also reminded me a lot of the one
from X-Men apocalypse where we see
Magneto's family getting killed in the
forest at this point we get a soldja boy
Cameo who's once more played by Jensen
knackles when we saw him last he was
being put under sedation but here we
have Kate's manifestation of him turns
out he was her imaginary boyfriend and
he goes into pretty deep detail about
what used to get up to Luke was of
course the number one at school so it
does make sense that she'd also
gravitate towards him hell both of them
self-destructed and there are
possibilities that his powers mutated to
be in line with what we saw Andre says
that he's a Russian agent and we
discovered he'd been experimented on by
them during season 3 this was clearly
ripping on the Winter Soldier with him
also of course being a Russian Sleeper
Cell he's freaked out by being called a
Russian and he was of course about
during a time with the Red Scare in
America Communists were put on trial and
the man just goes off on them I fart The
Star Spangled Banner you're pretty
[__] weird dude yeah knock knock
who's there go [__] your face now we
learn the lightning strikes of blood
vessels bursting and every time she uses
her power we of course see this
happening on her face so Bo goes to warn
them something really important but man
is mashed up and left in a pile of Ash I
was wondering if this was a play on his
death in the comics as he does get
brutally killed in that too now in the
real world we get to MMA eating with Sam
who's eating out of some vort tot twists
they have the puppet version of the deep
on them which explains where his Visions
come from to the left is a payback movie
poster and a salmon Emory night we see a
games machine with polar's Magneto
machine guessing that's as close as
we're going to get to them out now
saying Magneto and like him he is a
master of magnetism now Sam's never lost
that v card because he's been stuck in
the woods all that time but man needs no
help finding his way about the bush Emma
actually gets to be with someone who
wants to be with her instead of having
to shrink down however he does see her
as a puppet and we when we see that hand
smack against the glass it kind kind of
brings back memories of Titanic now as
they make their way through the woods
they come across a reconstruction of
Kate's room in it we see a post of a
soldja boy and Crimson CEST possibly
explaining where she got her Crush from
there's also a CEST poster on its own
who was based on Scarlet Witch and
having this in Kate's room yeah it does
make a lot of sense if you look closely
you can see that it says whiskey
Sunshine which is also riffing off the
film Tequila Sunrise as the queen May W
there too that riffing off the first
Wonder Woman film now as we can see
she's got a reinforced store with her
mother basically keeping her in prison
for 9 years shed's the first person who
seems like she's not afraid of her and
Professor Rex and Magneto used to do
something similar when meeting students
kind of felt like this build off the
back of the scene that open X-Men the
Last Stand with Shetty also offering a
way to make the voices stop she doesn't
go out and visit every single student
which we saw with Kate so her doing this
here shows that Kate's very special now
her reading the minds at the start is
what made her pass out and obviously she
needs to be kept under sedation not
doing this could bring the entire world
crashing down and the virus may have
even been in vented specifically for her
I actually think that she might be the
most powerful soup we've ever met in the
series and she has the potential to burn
down everything now we see the first
meeting she and Luke had with Andre
bearing the guilt of attacking his girl
in his death Luke confronts him and we
learn that Andre and Kate actually been
getting it on for a while now which
shows that he's not the good guy he
portrays himself as striking out and
killing dust in the group and fleeing of
the school and this is because they're
unable to use their powers they run
through the Brink's office and we see a
conference a in which lukee had once
more remembered his brother rather than
helping her friend though Jordan ended
up making him pass out which allowed Kay
to then Aras his memory and keep it
covered up he gives an inspirational
speech to Jordan similar to what he gave
to Marie and offers them the position of
ta and exchange for keeping quiet the
whole school's keeping things hush hush
and we also learn that brings been
augmenting Golden Boy this is how he
catapulted it up to number one and bring
said he wanted him to be homelander
strong the woods definitely seems like a
place where they're trying to build the
ultimate super weapon that can take down
any of the soups that might stand up
against them now Jordan saved their own
ass instead of saving their friend and
they sided with Brink just because he
was nice to them I think these are
showing the defining moments when they
could have been Heroes but really their
Hypocrites that screw over their friends
the only people who seem happy are Sam
and Emma but I feel like the pair are
completely doomed he's a fugitive and
she's going to have to choose whether
she wants the popularity or to go on the
run the pair took about how they wish
they could stay there forever which
again might be a play on the love scenes
from Titanic Either Way Emma says no
more running and we cut from a bird's
eye view shut of them lying down to the
rest of the group passed out according
to the words we see that Brink isn't
really juicing Luke and he's got them
passed out and doing what looks like
blood transfusions we discovered that
the school was using S boost Luke's
powers and this may even been the
strategy before they developed the virus
what they needed is a way to stop the
Rogue soups and having the most powerful
one under them their wing would be a way
to carry that out homelander was born in
a lab and they likely know that he had
Edgar ousted thus they need to bring
them down and we later discover that
Shetty completely hates them Kate was on
standby to make him forget and we see
all the times he came close to
remembering and she took the memories
away this clearly pushed Luca over the
deep end and this is what ended up
shoving him over the edge Kate known as
a pusher and she pushed him towards his
own death which makes her scene just
become really coldblooded now we see is
the school cracks and crumbles around
them and I feel this might be
foreshadowing of what's going to happen
in the season I might be wrong but
there's so many hints towards her and
the woods could bring the entire thing
crumbling down now finally they head up
Marie's where we see the aftermath of
her killing her parents seeing her
sister she apologizes for destroying
their family but in reality it wasn't
really her fault Marie was given V with
without the choice and her parents did
this just to make money Marie uses this
to show Kate that it is isn't really her
fault and that all of them are messed up
because of their parents' choices going
back to her room Andre talks her out of
it and she finally wakes up reminded me
a lot of the end of inception with them
finally managing to get out of the dream
and though they question their reality
the power still work at this point Sam
and Emma arrive and as the former
recognizes her he then goes on the
attack however he decides to spare her
and do the right thing and just like the
rest of the group he's starting to
become a hero now the words we see the
virus is actually capable of killing the
soups and loor's gutted shetes over the
moon she now wants to find a way to turn
it contagious which actually kind of
plays into a storyline at the end of the
comics now we'll be talking about what
happens in those first but I just want
to drop my thought on the episode and
then we'll get into what happens there
you really want to live then the single
most important thing I can tell you
is anyway I think that this was one of
the stand out episodes that when you
think back on the series this is going
to be one of the concepts that first
brings to mind going into a hero's head
and discovering their trauma through
their memories is such a cool creative
concept and it also worked as a way to
give us lots of big reveals on top of
that you had the cameos from people like
soldja boy which added a lot to it this
was basically Kate's backstory laid out
in such a cool fashion and it was a
really creative way to tell us about how
everything happened it also showed why
she's desperate to be accepted because
she's been shunned by even her own
family for something she can't help
really enjoyed it and you can see the
show starting to mount up with shed's
plot we still don't know who Marie's
benefactor is and I have seen some
comments saying that it might even be
shedy herself that could be the case but
I kind of think that she would be the
one to go out and get Maurice
specifically if that was true either way
really great entry and as for how this
could all be playing out we will be
going into Comic spoilers so if you
don't want to know what happens then
please check out now giving you another
countdown again we're not doing it just
to boost the the watch time on the video
we're really see serious about this
stuff um so in the comics homelander
ended up causing a super Uprising and he
stormed the White House and killed Vic
the vep Vic was the president at this
point so he wasn't technically the v um
but he was also a v plan as well
possibly showing what's going to happen
with Victoria but you went in to take
him out and at this point black noir
emerged and revealed himself to be a
clone of homelander he'd been created to
be someone that could bring homelander
down if he ever went Rog and now he was
finally getting to live out his purpose
they could do something like this in the
series 2 with the next Noir being a
version of homelander and Noir killed
him he finally took him out and then
Noir died at the hands of butcher
Butcher still had a vended against the
soups though and he put in place a plan
to take them out once and for all going
to the top of the Empire State Building
he was going to set off a radio
frequency that caused the V within soups
to make their heads explode this is
something that happened earlier in the
comics and it would take them out once
in for all now butcher ended up kind of
wanting huie to stop him which is the
main reason that he hired him he wanted
someone at his side who would Reign him
in which huy did and in the end he saved
the soups we saw a great reform in them
and ultimately in the end that they all
became better now I think the virus will
sort of be worked into it like that and
we might even get pandemic illusions
with it being something that makes the
soups ultimately start to act better cuz
Humanity acted better after the the
pandemic didn't it um and while that
might not happen I think the virus
itself could be something buter may
weaponized down the line potentially
even Vault will but it's clearly playing
into the overall boys story and I'm
guessing it's going to be very important
down the line anyway that's our thoughts
on it and make sure you leave yours
below please drop a like on the video
and if you want to support the channel
as a member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button to get
early access to videos every week and it
goes such a long way to helping us make
these you want to get some heavy
spoilers merch we've also got our
t-shirt line located just below the
video that will let you pick up all
kinds of tops like our Theory time on
House of dragon stuff Marvel te's and a
lot more we drop new designs on there
all the time too so definitely keep an
eye out for them if you want something
else to watch we've got a video on
screen right now without the way huge
thank you for sing through the video
I've been your host Paul and I'll see
you next time you take care peace